hey ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder was
leckeres zum mittagessen oder zum
abendessen wir machen wieder ein
leckeres nudelgericht und ich liebe euch
dafür dass ihr immer nudelgerichte sehen
möchtet denn da sind wir voll auf einer
wellenlänge ich liebe nudelgerichte ich
kann es nicht verhindern ich möchte am
liebsten hinter knuddeln ist ist
natürlich auch nicht so gesund aber was
ich heute mache ist so ein bisschen eine
fettarme variante von einer käse sahne
soße und wir nehmen brokkoli mit rein
also richtig richtig lecker willkommen
jetzt die richtigen zutaten
wir benötigen nudel in eurer wahl
außerdem gemüsebrühe und fettreduzierte
sahne
hier habe ich natürlich brokkoli käse
außerdem zwiebeln knoblauch und olivenöl
hier habe ich noch etwas salz und
pfeffer also pfeffer und salz muskat
muss und eine prise zucker und wir
beginnen jetzt direkt mit der leckeren
soße ich habe die nudeln jetzt auf
meinem richtigen herz zum kochen
gebracht das ist ein vorgang in mist das
kriegt ihr alle natürlich hin und dann
habe ich hier genug platz euch die soße
zu zeigen und jetzt habe ich eine
beschichtete pfanne und gebt mir meine
rein und jetzt wird das so auch
mittlerer stufe erhitzt und dann werden
wir die zwiebeln und die knoblauchzehe
der sich beide komplett fein gehackt
wenn wir einfach andünsten so zwei
minuten das reicht
[Musik]
zur zwiebeln und knoblauch sind jetzt
richtig schön angedünstet wichtig ist
halt wirklich nur dass er nicht die
volle pulle nimmt sondern nur die
mittlere stufe dann kann das auch
richtig schön langsam diensten und jetzt
nehmen wir uns unser mehl das dient
einfach der bindung später geben das
einfach locker drauf und dann schön
miteinander verrühren und die mittlere
stufe ganz wichtig beibehalten
das mehl habe ich jetzt ca 30 sekunden
lange in der pfanne angeschwitzt und
jetzt wird das ganze abgelöscht
die mit zuallererst gemüsebrühe und dann
liefert reduzierte seine ihr könnt jetzt
an der stelle auch ein schneebesen
nehmen das macht es für einige
vielleicht einfacher ich bei speziellen
kochlöffel und dann wird das klümpchen
frei verrührt und hier gebe ich noch
einen entscheidenden tipp gibt immer nur
so ein bisschen rein arbeitet euch das
schluck für schluck vor
weil wenn ihr alles auf einmal rein gibt
dann habt ihr wahrscheinlich klümpchen
und das ist es dann wirklich nicht so
schön
[Musik]
so und das ist jetzt die basis für
unsere soße ich habe jetzt gemüsebrühe
und die fed reduzierte seine drin alles
schön klümpchen frei verrührt und jetzt
könnt ihr gerne auch mal die hitze hoch
stellen
denn in den letzten fünf minuten also
jetzt quasi geben wir unseren brokkoli
mit dazu es hat den brokkoli hier schon
in kleine mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten und den strunk den brauchen
wir nicht ich habe ihn aber auch über
den könnt ihr gerne in suppe zum
beispiel ergeben also nicht wegschmeißen
dass er wirklich zu schade
so und jetzt den brokkoli dazugeben fünf
minuten lang mit köcheln lassen oder mit
garen lassen und dann wird er richtig
schön durch das ganze fängt schon
langsam an zu küchen ich gebe an der
stelle auch schon die gewürze mit dazu
der zucker der rundet den geschmack noch
mal ab und ich gibt sogar immer gerne
bei brokkoli mit dazu
ich weiß nicht ob wir das kennt manchmal
schmeckt mir brokkoli so ein bisschen
bitter von zucker wickler so ein
bisschen entgegen muskatnuss nämlich
auch gerne wer das nicht mag oder nicht
da kann es ganz einfach weglassen mit
dem salz bin ich vorsichtig das nämlich
gleich erst weil ihr habt ja gleich noch
käse drin und die gemüsebrühe aber
pfeffer gebe ich auch schon mit dazu
[Musik]
so die brokkoli röschen dürfen jetzt in
der soße baden ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen eingetaucht und jetzt gebe ich
wie gesagt den deckel drauf fünf minuten
dauert das bei mir weil ich habe relativ
kleines stückchen wenn ihr größere
stückchen habt dann dauert es vielleicht
sieben oder acht minuten in der
zwischenzeit sind auch schon die nudeln
auf dem anderen herz fertig dann kommt
noch der käse drauf und dann sind wir
endlich fertig
[Musik]
so der brokkoli isst gar den herd könnte
jetzt ausschalten dann brauchen wir
nicht mehr so und jetzt geben wir nur
noch den käse dazu die rest hitze reicht
vollkommen das schmilzt der käse euch
auch schon und ich sage euch leute das
ist so lecker krieg bestimmt schon
westring mund grad genauso wie ich ja
selbst du
[Musik]
so jetzt ist alles fertig ihr müsst nur
noch anrichten an der stelle aber
unbedingt noch mal ein bisschen
nachsalzen vielleicht ist es auch nicht
nötig weil wie gesagt gerne und
gemüsebrühe enthalten schon genug salz
und ich mach das mal gerne so dass ich
jetzt die nudeln direkt zur sauce gebe
alles miteinander vermengen und dann
sehen wir
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt nicht mehr viel zu
sagen genießt einfach die leckere nudeln
mit der brokkoli sahnesoße schreibt mir
auf jeden fall hier unten in die
kommentare welches nudelgericht die als
nächstes sehen möchtet und dann mache
ich das für euch sehr gerne die genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer hier unten in die infobox ich
freue mich wenn ihr dem video ein
dörfchen nach oben gibt natürlich ein
kostenloses abo wenn ihr das nicht schon
längst getan habt und dann sehen wir uns
hoffentlich auch beim nächsten mal
wieder auf katys kitchen übrigens müssen
wir unbedingt auf instagram folgen denn
da frage ich euch immer was als nächstes
kommen soll und dann halte ich mich da
auch wirklich dran und haben sie zeigt
euch immer der sport immer auf instagram
also los river zu instagram also bis
dann tschüss
[Musik]